all right we've had some amazing
makeovers this week but have you ever
heard of a money makeover
yes well we're teaming up with chime to
learn how to get one and here to share
how you can get your finances to a
beautiful place is our friend money
expert and award-winning author melissa
leong
welcome back to the show oh thank you
this for me is such a important subject
and i can't think of anyone better to
discuss it with you
what is a money makeover melissa
well a money makeover is just a new
approach or new strategy to refresh your
finances and i promise that a money
makeover can drastically change the way
that you feel about yourself and the
look of your life okay well melissa
you're gonna pull the studio audience
using our flower poles
and figure out how to approach
getting the best makeover and you're
going to share some tips based on the
responses
okay first question to our audience
which common problem area causes you
more stress lines having too much debt
or
not having enough retirement savings so
hold up the red flower for debt and the
green flower for retirement savings
oh
what do you think drew
is that a good mix
maybe kind of seems like a very even
steven so what approach if we do have a
okay you suggest for both so everybody
gets something out of it well listen
both of those issues are big issues i
hear you and according to the federal
reserve only 36 of americans actually
feel like they're ready
for retirement when it comes to their
retirement safety that's a low number
and so i get that when you are far from
your goals you think uh i'm so far i'm
not even going to try but every little
bit counts savings is a habit you got to
get into saving even if it's just say 15
of your income or more depending on your
age or situation and into various
savings
mechanisms like you know a savings
account or maybe your 401k plan just
want to make sure that you make that a
habit for everybody who said debt
i also understand
debt is one of the most stressful things
that we can deal with in a long list of
stressful events getting into debt
beyond means of repayment ranks number
five five that's more stressful than
your spouse cheating on you more
stressful than
conflict with your boss so one method to
tackle that would be to
list all of your debts
and with their interest rates and then
while making the minimum payment on all
of them just pick one maybe the highest
interest rate or maybe the smallest debt
and then attack it ferociously like
throw whatever you can at it and if you
need to build credit bringing down your
credit balances can help your score
improve over time also set a calendar
reminder so that you are never late on a
payment another option would be to check
out chime secured credit builder visa
credit card not only are there no annual
fees no interest and no credit check to
apply
you can use it on everyday purchases to
help build credit which can have a
positive impact on your credit score
with regular on-time payments all you
need is a chime spending account and a
200 qualifying direct deposit and you're
ready to apply okay here's the next
question for our audience
when it comes to your money do you feel
like you need a little financial
touch-up or an all-over head-to-toe
transformation green flower for just a
little touch-up
and red flower for a total overhaul
seems like
a a little bit more is in the green well
many makeovers maybe fresh and answering
questions just so again everybody here
gets something so
regardless of which makeover you're
getting the all-over makeover or the
mini refresh you would start by again
looking at your situation get extreme
clarity on the income
and the x uh the expenses your expenses
and so you are downloading your bank
statements you're looking at the inflow
and outflow of your money and you're
also getting a sense of what your money
habits have been you know ask yourself
what were the last three unplanned
purchases that i made
and why did i make them yeah and so i
just think it's important to check in
with yourself to make sure that your
spending is in line with your values
and
your uh your goals okay can you give us
like one tip that we could all
start doing today
that might be a money-saving
planet-saving just something we weren't
thinking to do this way
write down your goals
but they have to be specific and so when
i'm overwhelmed i like to write things
down and so if you just write down three
you know
short-term mid-term and long-term goals
these goals
like i know short-term is sticking to
your budget for the holidays long-term
might be retirement like decades out
and then break them up into many
bite-sized goals so if you want to save
a thousand dollars to add to your
emergency fund that's automating a
transfer of 40 bucks
a week
into a high yield savings account 40
bucks a week save 40 bucks a week
i i i like that
tip thank you melissa
oh my goodness thank you so much so
welcome our lives better and more
knowledgeable and less stressful which
does
cause for a more beautiful life a more
beautiful feeling inside and therefore
a more relaxed effortless outside um
thank you
[Music]
you